sitting here listening to my music list
and I'm starting to find a little
clarity starting to understand why this
thing is so hard
of entrepreneurship [ __ ] this game of
life it's because the real answer is
really found when you're pulling from
opposite directions send your legs
saying why why why am I so glass why is
all this good stuff happening
I'm a contradiction because um I've got
this funny juxtaposition where I'm
pulling from opposite directions I don't
give a [ __ ] what any of you think about
me yet hoping to every comment and I'll
listen to everything all of you say
about me
cuz I listen I talk a buck load I'm
always talking I'm cutting people off of
talking but I'm listening I'm listening
24/7 I'm always patient I playing the
long game but I'm always quitting things
every day try and testing not crippled
by stopping starting how do I figure
that out how do I understand when it's
time to give up on something or when
it's time to persevere how do I
understand how do I feel
and how do I decide when to listen to
somebody's feedback or to know when
they're trolling or don't give a [ __ ] or
only certain seek service level how how
is this happening how am i working 24/7
365 yet it doesn't feel it I'm working
how am I always constantly putting out
content building my brand you have never
about it just living my life how am i
documented instead of creating where is
this where is this set coming from where
is this call to action coming from why
is this plan working so well and now how
do I get all you youngsters and when I
say youngsters I mean the 59 year old
who hasn't grown up yet who hasn't been
willing to look at
and it comes from this comes from the
most macro it's cleared up from them
start to see it it's understanding that
nobody gives a [ __ ] and then that's ok
that's the way it should be
I live on empathy you shouldn't give a
[ __ ] you got you to worry about I'm
empathetic to that that's the game and
we're all dealt with different cards
we've all got strengths and weaknesses
we've got the advantages and the
disadvantages tiny sea white privilege
so do I I see privilege and being from
the streets and having zero and being
hungrier there's so many different ways
and of course some are better than
others at the most back row but I don't
even spend the time to figure that out
because by the time you figure out if it
was fair you're [ __ ] finished and so
instead of doing that I do and I do and
I do and I'm always planning and I'm not
planning and I've always got a game plan
and a strategy and I've always not got
one I'm just going off the hip from
intuition from learned behavior from
pattern recognition because I've been
doing this from again when it was 12 13
14 15 I knew I did it's why I got there
Sigrid's shout out to everybody saw that
with our guard on Instagram you know
it's what I do and so as I sit here lay
and look and think a debate look out at
the auction and listen to this music
it's becoming clearer 2017 can be a
great year not just for me but for you
because I find clarity I'm gonna
suffocate negativity I'm gonna suffocate
excuses if you're going to be in my
community you're going to give up and
leave
if you want to believe in those things
because I'm gonna pound it push it press
it harder than I ever had before because
the truth is I'm thankful I'm grateful
I'm working on myself
24/7 my goals my ambitions and I'm
working on your goals and your ambitions
24/7 that's pulling VirB opposite
directions that's what I do that's what
I do harder stronger better than anybody
honey Empire [ __ ] build the biggest
building of all time the biggest best
business of all time
like a [ __ ] tortoise like a slow
[ __ ] tortoise ship away everyday
underestimated all along the way got my
fans who are delusional I got the rest
of the majority of the market that
doesn't think I can get it that doesn't
see the behavior because they're
thinking 2017 they're thinking 2019
they're thinking 2021
I'm thinking like [ __ ] I'm thinking
[ __ ] life and so I promise you
come you be the people that are
listening to this right now you've given
me the greatest [ __ ] gift at all you
keep your $500 masterclasses you keep
your $5,000 masterminds you keep your
$97 ebooks you keep that in your pocket
and you do you your gifting me with the
greatest [ __ ] thing on earth
your attention and your word-of-mouth
every [ __ ] time to tag somebody in my
comments on Instagram every time you
share my story on snapchat every time
you post and share on Facebook means the
world to me
every between means the world to me that
means you're putting me on
your co-signing this [ __ ] journey and
for that I will never take it for
granted I love you happy 2017
[Music]